welcome back so we just figured out how
long does this thing stay in the air so
what can we do with that let me clear
all of this and redraw it because I have
maybe every time I redraw it it might
further clarify things
actually let me let me actually draw
things a little bit fancier this time so
I have the ball and it's moving look at
that let me just draw the triangle ahead
of time
and I'm going to use fancy a whoops
actually let me use a thicker line so
this was the initial vector that I
wanted to do switch to green this is its
horizontal going to draw the arrows in a
second I just want to get all the line
tool work out of the way BAM and then
this is the close enough and then if I
draw it use my paint tool I could draw a
arrow there
switch back to green draw an arrow there
switch back to magenta draw an arrow
there so this was 10 meters per second
10 meters per second at a 45 degree
angle we figured out in the last video
that it's horizontal velocity is equal
to 10 cosine of 45 which equals 5 square
roots of 2 and we also figured out that
the vertical velocity is equal to 10
sine of 45 degrees 10 sine of 45 degrees
which also equals 5 square roots of 2
and we wanted to figure out how long
does this think they stay in the air and
we said well if we're if we're going the
vertical component is 5 square roots of
2 meters per second so if I'm going 5
square roots of 2 meters per second hot
the ball how long does it take for the
ball to go from that point to the point
that it's stationary at the top of its
path right so let's go it's going at
five square roots of 2 meters per second
and then it goes to 0 right so how long
does it take to decelerate from 5 square
roots of 2 to
and there we just said you know change
in velocity well my change in velocity
is minus five square roots of two that
equals acceleration which is minus ten
meters per second squared times time and
we figured out the time to when the ball
leaves to kind of its highest point is
to is is the square root of two seconds
and that happens if you just solve this
equation and that's how long the ball
takes to go from the ground to its
highest point and is going to take the
exact amount of time for it to
re-accelerate and come back down right
so it takes
square roots of two seconds to go up and
it's going to take square roots of two
seconds to go down so the total time so
total time total time is equal to two
square roots of 2 all right this is the
total time this is kind of a nice
intermediate thing that we've discovered
now can we use this to figure out how
far does that ball travel how far is
this sucker going to go well the entire
time that you know we were messing
around with the vertical speed or the
vertical velocity of this ball on the
vertical acceleration in the vertical
position the whole time if the ball was
going up and down it was also going to
the right because it has this it has
this horizontal velocity right and we're
going to assume that the horizontal
velocity stays constant and why can we
assume that well one we're assuming that
there's no air resistance because air
resistance makes very things a lot very
complicated and if this is something
like a penny or a marble it actually
does have very little air resistance so
air isn't going to slow it down and so
if there's no air what can slow it down
in d in the in the horizontal direction
well nothing gravity only acts downwards
right gravity doesn't make something
slow down as it moves horizontally I
mean you can imagine some pushing
something on ice and if there's nothing
slowing it down no friction no air
resistance it'll just keep on going and
actually you know what the assumptions
we're making would be absolutely true on
the moon because the moon has no air
anyway so the whole time the ball is
going up and down it's also moving to
the right at this speed at five square
roots of two meters per second right and
let me ask you a question how long is it
going to be moving to the right
well it's going to be moving to the
right as long as it's up in the air and
do we know how long it's going to be up
in the air well yeah we just figured
that out right we figured out that it
stays in the air for two square roots of
two seconds so to figure out its
horizontal distance to figure out how
long it is along the ground so you know
we could say change in distance
horizontally or you know yeah change in
distance horizontally that just equals
my average velocity which is just this
because it doesn't really change so it
equals five square roots of two meters
per second times the time that I'm in
the air times two square roots of two
seconds times this sucker to square root
of two seconds so when we multiply it
out see we can a to ten times square
root of 2 times square root two is two
times two so we go 20 meters 20 meters
that I think is pretty cool all I did is
I said well I'm throwing something at at
10 meters per second at a 45 degree
angle how far did it go and now you
could you could you could figure it out
you could figure out that it went 20
meters and actually you could do things
the other way I mean we will and I'll do
that in future problems you can figure
out the exact angle you need to throw
something it or you need to shoot
something if we were thinking military
terms you know if you were if you were
an artillery man and you have to arm the
you have to figure out what angle to to
shoot the big gun at to shoot a target I
don't know five miles away not that I
advocate these type of things were very
bad you would be doing essentially this
problem I don't know if if people in the
military are actually doing it they're
probably having a computer do it for
them but it's really not that hard to do
and you know if we ever lose our
computers and we have to do things with
bows and arrows it's good to be able to
to sit down and do the math like this so
that's all I'm going to do for well we
could do a couple of other things too we
can also figure out how high the ball
went and how high the ball went is is
actually no different than the one
dimensional problem right we know that
this is the initial velocity in its
upward direction we know it goes to zero
so it's average velocity in the upward
direction
is going to be what it's average
velocity in the upward direction is
going to be this Plus this divided by
two so the average or is the average
horizontal velocity vertical velocity
sorry
vertical velocity average I don't know
this is funny notation it's going to be
half of this it's going to be 5 square
roots of 2 over 2 and so and it travels
that for how long
well just while it's going up it travels
that 4 square root of 2 seconds times
the square root of 2 seconds right so
distance is the average velocity times
time so this is this equal this square
root of 2 times this square root of 2 is
2 and it cancels out with this so the
the peak height that we could say the
height is going to be 5 meters so that's
pretty neat if I throw something at 10
meters per second at a 45 degree angle
its maximum height is going to be 5
meters and it's going to go 20 meters so
I could draw that image clear image
image invert colors so let me draw my
ground oh whoops
so I'm going to draw my ground it's kind
of a yellow ocher ground and I'm going
to shoot something at I'm going to shoot
something at an angle 45 degrees at 10
meters per second and we figured out
that it will go 20 meters and its
maximum height is going to be let's see
this is 10 so I'm trying to draw
something kind of scale so its maximum
height is roughly 5 meters it is exactly
5 meters I'm roughly is what I'm drawing
and so its path is going to look
something like this it's gonna you know
right from the get-go it's at that angle
but the angle is going to get shallower
and shallower BAM is the 5 meters and it
comes down and then it hits the ground
you know what thud so there you go we
just figure out how far does that thing
go and how high does it go what else
what else could you want so in the next
video I'm going to do this more
generally so that we can kind of you
know we can work backwards if we knows
how far something went and how long it
was in the air maybe we could figure out
its angle or maybe we could actually
figure out what the optimal angle is to
throw something for distance I'll see
you in the next video